Aloha crew it's Tuesday night rich and I
just got in from our nail help run that
just freakin work best hour and a half
swim this morning at Kona aquatics and
then worked all day and then put in a
nice 90-minute build Ron Connolly he
drive in the dark yeah it's dark for the
second half three down pretty hard so
we're pretty beat we're back to the
house we're all loaded up some more
nutrition products front of Jason's to
send us thanks Rebecca
we love you busted out you robbed a
Becca keep the goods coming we're gonna
make history in two weeks and we got a
big surprise in the mail today and I am
so stoked our buddy tonnage at Tai
graphics you can check them out online
at Tai graphics calm its ta IGRA pH XCOM
and ty does zip wheel stickers race
wheels a lot of you guys saw my never
stop stickers that went on my 404s and
808 he's the best in the industry is the
best t-shirt and the industry checker
check out what about dog just got you
just sent us some prototypes of the joy
ultra crew shirt for ultra man that's my
new logo for my company guy ultra life
performance spirit and then on the back
we got the sweet try lab logo it's a
ploy and exploiting Theresa and then we
got confident descended health logo he's
sending us some amazing nutrition
products that we're gonna talk about in
the upcoming days he's really having
edge of nutrition and wellness is doing
some amazing things and then this is the
logos for Sportiva import touring and
suicide thanks mark he's my son our
sponsor so it's a pretty cool tide an
unbelievable job is your amazing shirts
and these are Sorel running tech shirts
these these will be going on royal dogs
website after Ultraman stickers oh that
is so sweet
ty you nailed it bro we got some small
ones I'm gonna try to find a place on my
bike so pretty excited about all this
swag I'm gonna order up a bunch of these
and roll dog and I are any of you guys
out there I want to buy one of these I'm
gonna try to make some of these
available to for purchase we'll talk
about that later but these are we be
putting those on your Facebook yes Rosa
what are we doing them all tomorrow we
got one hour ocean swim and then 4 hours
on the bike supposed to do some climbing
intervals so we're thinking about maybe
going up to javi and climbing up the
koalas or maybe gone over one
and doing a couple times over there
we'll see we got a flash flood watch
warning today on the island for the next
three days so we're gonna don't don't
don't hit me do it either brutal huh so
we're going to we're gonna check out and
see where the rain has a comment so that
we can go the opposite way but I think
it's coming in from kawaii so we're
gonna I think we're gonna maybe I don't
know we might have to go south but we'll
jump on the net tonight and check out
how the weather is we're gonna grind now
model all that you do my quads are
thrashed yeah
I'm pretty tired roll dog is a beast for
all you guys out there don't ever let
him kiss you he's been training for a
year for this race so he he threw all
his cards on the table he's at the
blackjack table right now Vegas threw
all his cards on the table for this race
and he's training like a madman I was
trying to catch him on I'll beat you dry
and it was just like no go but yeah I
ran in the dark for good what 30 minutes
yeah and good stuff though good vibe
we're getting ready to wind down when
our last hard week and hey thanks for
stopping by we're gonna continue to
bring you with us on this amazing
journey into the 2009 ultraman World
Championships and all right this is the
this is the kind chia seeds go get
something all right
yeah peace out
plants strong we'll catch you